un científico de alimentos quiere
estimar la diferencia entre los pesos
medios de huevos clasificados como
enorme y grande se planea tomar una
muestra de cada tipo de huevo para
construir un intervalo t de dos muestras
cuáles de las siguientes condiciones
aplican para este tipo de intervalo
antes de ver todas las respuestas
observa que aquí dice elige todas las
respuestas que apliquen así que puede
ser más de uno pensemos en cuáles son
las condiciones para la inferencia que
existen para este tipo de intervalo
bueno esto ya lo hemos hecho muchas
veces en diferentes contextos y sabemos
que primero tenemos la condición de
aleatoriedad que va con la idea de que
cada una de las muestras es aleatoria o
estamos realizando algún tipo de
experimento en donde asignamos
aleatoriamente en este caso asignamos
huevos a uno de los dos grupos es decir
que tomamos dos muestras y esperamos que
realmente sean
y la segunda es la condición de
normalidad la condición de normalidad es
un poco diferente dependiendo de si
estamos hablando de medias o de
proporciones la condición de
aleatoriedad es esencialmente la misma
como en este caso estamos hablando de
medias porque recuerden que se busca
estimar la diferencia entre los pesos
medios de huevos existen varias formas
en las que podemos satisfacer la
condición de normalidad una forma es si
la distribución subyacente es normal y
la segunda forma es si el tamaño de la
muestra para cada una de las muestras es
mayor o igual a 30 entonces si el tamaño
de la primera muestra es mayor o igual a
30 y el tamaño de la segunda muestra es
mayor o igual a 30 o incluso si no
conocemos los datos de la distribución
subyacente ya sea una distribución
normal o no incluso si no se cumplen
estas condiciones del tamaño de las
muestras mientras los datos muestrales
sean aproximadamente
y no tengan una fuerte asimetría hacia
un lado o hacia el otro entonces cuando
trabajamos con medias también se cumple
aproximadamente la condición de
normalidad y la tercera condición ya sea
que estemos trabajando con medias o
proporciones o diferencias de medias o
diferencias de proporciones es la
condición de independencia y esta es la
idea de que ya sea que las observaciones
individuales se hacen con reemplazo en
las dos muestras o que el tamaño de la
muestra para las dos muestras no es
mayor del 10% de la población si ocurre
eso entonces se cumple la condición así
que con ese pequeño repaso veamos cuáles
de estas respuestas aplican se
observaron al menos 10 huevos pesados y
10 huevos ligeros en cada muestra bueno
esta es la condición de normalidad
cuando trabajamos con proporciones no
medias así que voy a descartar esta
opción que es un buen distractor los
huevos en cada muestra fueron
aleatoriamente de su población si esa es
la condición de aleatoriedad así que la
seleccionamos se muestra el mismo número
de cada tipo de huevo este es un
concepto erróneo muy común el cual dice
que si trabajamos con medias o con
proporciones cuando pensamos en la
diferencia entre las medias o la
diferencia de las proporciones de alguna
manera los tamaños de las muestras
tienen que ser exactamente iguales y
aquí no es el caso los tamaños de las
muestras no tienen que ser iguales así
que también descartamos esta opción
entonces aquí nos han listado la
condición de aleatoriedad aunque también
pudieron habernos puesto la condición de
normalidad y la condición de
independencia nos vemos en otro vídeo